just what we got started with this one I
do want to address the fact that I
recently covered Rasputin on another one
of my channel so we kind of thought is
it really necessary to do it here on
biographic saz well however it has been
requested so much that here we are if
you want to check out that other video
I'm going to link to that below as well
but for now let's get into it
[Music]
grigory rasputin was a Russian peasant
who claimed to have mystic healing
powers and he even went so far as to say
that he was the second coming of Christ
he formed his own cult and even
manipulated members of the raw Romanov
family into believing that he truly was
a holy man once he had everyone wrapped
around his little finger he used his
influence over the Russian government
since his decisions contributed to the
downfall of the Romanov dynasty for
years he claims that he struggled
between the forces of good and evil many
priests believed that his powers didn't
come from God at all and that he was
actually the Antichrist
grigory rasputin was born on January the
20th 1869 in a Siberian village called
Pro cough spray for years Siberia had
been something of a dumping ground for
Russia's criminals and there were a lot
of prison colonies that were full of men
doing hard labor there were also people
there who had been exiled to Siberia for
their religious or political beliefs it
is one of the coldest and most difficult
places to live and survival there is a
constant struggle
Rasputin's father he was a peasant
farmer and a courier and his mother gave
birth to seven children before he was
born all of them died during childbirth
or in early infancy so it was actually
the first to survive the harsh Siberian
winter there's a boy he claims that he
would have visions of the future and
that angels appeared to him in his
dreams he knew things about his
neighbors that he couldn't possibly know
which was enough evidence to make the
locals believe him he could heal horses
who were sick just by touching them some
villagers believed that he was the
second coming of Christ and that he was
simply touched by God others believed
that he was demonic and could
potentially be working with a devil in
his teens and early twenties it would
seem that the latter was tree because he
was apparently very badly behaved he
would drink he would steal and he'd
generally just get on everyone's nerves
a 28 years old he was married and had
four children with his wife who he met
in a neighboring village he had a
reputation of being an abusive alcoholic
and also cheated on his wife one day he
stole a horse when word got out that he
was a horse thief instead of facing the
consequences he galloped towards a local
monastery for sanctuary and ended up
staying with the Christian Brothers for
several months they had convinced him to
find God and change his evil ways a man
names mockery became his mentor and he
decided to actually join the order and
become a monk he abandoned his family in
favour of traveling from place to place
evangelizing to various villages many
historians believe that if he spent so
much time walking through the forest of
Siberia was always guaranteed that he
would run into a cult called the Christi
these people were an offshoot of the
Russian Orthodox Church and many of
their members would actually show up to
a normal Mass on Sunday and have secret
meetings in the woods they believed that
salvation could only be achieved through
purging sin they would perform
ceremonies where they choked
Varun's let go at the last moment so
they would get high on asphyxiation they
spoke in tongues and would spin and
dance until they felt drunk they would
work themselves into a frenzy and then
fall to the ground then they would let
out their pent-up desires by having sex
with whoever was lying next to them in a
massive orgy Rasputin continued to
travel and evangelize the Christian
faith but this wasn't your normal
run-of-the-mill visit from someone with
a Bible
these monk Wanderers were not allowed to
bathe and Rasputin sometimes wore
shackles as he walked to make himself
feel pain on purpose this was supposed
to be in atonement for his sins by the
time he returned to his village to see
his family and friends again he was a
completely changed man his eyes stared
on with a frightening intensity and he
said that his visions from gods they
were stronger than ever even though he
only just got home he told his wife that
he needed to use the basement as a
meeting place for his religious group
where he continued to have orgies with
his Kristi friends
one day Rasputin claims that the Virgin
Mary appeared before him and told him to
go to some Petersburg to help the royal
family the idea that the royal family
could need help from a peasant man in
Siberia was totally insane so well how
on earth did someone like Rasputin make
his way into the raw palace well it
turns out that his mentor from the
monastery Macari was actually the former
religious advisor to the Romanovs he was
likely able to use McCurry's connections
to attract a noble clients who believed
in Rasputin's abilities and people were
simply amazed at his powers rich people
they were willing to travel all the way
to his small village to be healed by him
Macari sent a letter of introduction to
one of his friends in some Petersburg
and Rasputin went on the long journey to
that City he met Bishop ham again and a
high-level priest named Sergei troof
enough who is better known as Illya dog
at first the men were shocked by
Rasputin's disheveled appearance he
smelled truly awful and his stare it was
terrifying
he was able to dilate his eyes at will
making them appear to be almost fully
black but once the priest saw his
healing ability he said that he must be
a saint who was gifted by the powers of
God but Rasputin truly did not care at
all about what people thought of him he
would pick his nose and eat it in front
of dignified people and mark eres de
Craddock women for their heirs he
actually became good friends with
princess Miller Curran's Anastasia of
Montenegro who were nicknamed the crow
sisters because of the shape of their
noses they were not Russian but they
still managed to marry into the Romanov
family that actually both been heavily
involved in mysticism and the occult and
they both manipulated their way into
marrying members of the royal family
they were often treated as outcasts by
the rest of the aristocracy so they
bonded with Rasputin and took him under
their wing all of this was perfect
timing because Tsarina Alexandra Roman
offers just lost her first spiritual
advisor a man named dr. Philippe she
believed that he helped her and Tsar
Nicholas have a son and heir to the
throne after having only daughters he
claims on his deathbed that she would
meet another holy man very soon
who would take his place almost
immediately after this the crow sisters
introduced Rasputin to the Tsar and
Tsarina at a party the sisters have been
the ones who helped this arena fine to
previous mystic so when Alexandra
learned of this
stories of Rasputin's miraculous healing
abilities she knew that she wanted him
to help us on Alexi he was born with
hemophilia which is a condition that
prevents blood from clotting this means
that even a small scrape can lead to
massive blood loss they never told
Rasputin about their son's condition at
the party and it was a secret they had
attempted to keep quiet Alexandra was
still considering whether or not she
could trust this peasant from Siberia
but one day Alexei fell ill and scraped
his knee and the bleeding was not
stopping Rasputin showed up out of
nowhere to the Royal Palace demanding to
see the boy he said that he had a vision
from gods and that without him the
prince would die in reality he most
likely learned about this insider
information from The Crow sisters but to
the gods and the royal family they were
shocked wondering how he could have
possibly known once he was allowed to
see him he told the doctors to leave so
that he could use his healing powers
almost immediately Alexei actually did
begin to heal and this was enough to
convince Alexandra that he was truly a
holy man who had magical healing powers
modern date scientists and historians
believe that this was not magic surprise
surprise but that he was actually
preventing the doctors from giving Alexi
aspirin which would thin his blood and
only make his haemophilia worse within
just a few months Rasputin became a
regular installment in the Romanov
family mansion he began to give drugs
like opium morphine and cocaine to the
Tsar claiming that they would help him
with his various ailments they would get
high together on a regular basis the
Tsar became addicted which only made him
want Rasputin to come by the palace more
often the Tsarina would get migraine
headaches and suffered from anxiety and
Rasputin was able to take away her pain
and get her to relax soon enough the
Tsar and Tsarina they began to feel a
dependency on him and he started to
visit at least once a week Rasputin
called Alexandra and Nikolas mama and
papa raised if he was one of the kids he
began to pray with the children at night
and tell them bedtime stories this made
that nanny very nervous because the
oldest daughters were already beginning
to go through puberty one of the maids
also claims that Rasputin's had raped
her however the Tsarina trusted Rasputin
so much that she accused the maid of
lying and fired her the nanny tried to
kick Rasputin out of the nursery but the
children claims that Rasputin was their
friends and kin
that the nanny was mean so well she was
fired as well it was clear that
Rasputin's claws were deep in the raw
family and he could get away with just
about anything
newspapers around some Petersburg they
began to print stories about the
incident saying that Rasputin was very
literally let into the princess's beds
[Music]
Rasputin lived in an apartment in Saint
Petersburg where his followers could
come and have meetings with him
women would all show up with a hot dish
and they had potluck style parties they
gathered around the table with him
sitting at the center Rasputin would sit
in silence staring into space when
suddenly he would begin to mumble
something
the women would immediately stop talking
in hopes of understanding what he was
trying to say he would then grab paper
and desperately write down whatever was
on his mind
first some insane and inexplicable
reason this was incredibly attractive to
these women they believed that he was
the second coming of Christ and they
would offer to go with him into his
bedroom and have sex with him one
disciple in particular all-girl octina
had so much faith in him that she left
her husband and children in order to
live in his apartment she forced
everyone to address him as got witnesses
opened the back door to see Olga holding
his penis and screaming you are Christ
and I am yours
mence ever walked in on this unfortunate
scene while they slowly backed away
shutting the door on their way out after
learning about the scandal police
officers were ordered to follow him to
see what he would do they reported that
he would hire prostitutes on almost
daily basis and bring them into bath
houses now you would think that if he
was paying for a bath on a daily basis
he might actually smell good but
according to testimonies he would bring
a prostitute into a private room where
they would both get undressed he would
then take his leather belt and begin
beating the woman claiming that he would
beat the sin of lechery out of her soul
then they would have sex with Aron's
leave the bathhouse without even
touching the water
he was once witnessed-- leaving a
bathhouse and screaming at the demons
that he could feel inside of him he
would say that he could see the devil in
himself and he said that there was a
battle over a soul going on now
obviously this might sound like he was
trippin on one of the many drugs that he
happened to be taking but remember those
two priests Bishop Hannigan and Illya
door well they happened to hear about
rest Bouton's screaming about demons in
public and this was damaging the
reputation since they were the ones who
introduced Rasputin to some petersburg
society halligan and alinor ambushed
Rasputin to confront him about what he
was doing they accused him of using the
devil to have these healing powers
humming and grabbed her ass Who am I the
penis and screams that he was thinking
with that
rather than his brain these two came
prepared with a giant wooden crucifix
which they used the beaten just about as
bloody as he would be those prostitutes
in a bathhouse that the power of Christ
did not compel him Rasputin tattled on
them to the Tsarina saying that they
were trying to murder him ham again and
Iliad or WA then both sent into exile
and Iliad or fled to Finland dressed as
a woman so that no one could trace where
he was going
at the same time Rasputin decided that
he needed a break from the city and
visited his home in Siberia
it turns out that Iliad or truly was
trying to kill Rasputin and he later
confessed to all of the details in a
biography he was convinced that Rasputin
was the Antichrist so he hired a
disfigured prostitute named keyonna
guseva to kill him she had been so
abused by a former client that they had
cut her nose off her face just leaving a
gaping hole in a door told her the
stories of how Rasputin beat and abused
other sex workers she showed up to his
village and waited for him outside of
his home Rasputin received a telegram in
the mail and left the house he needed to
go to the post office to attend a reply
it was then that he noticed a woman
standing and staring at him he decided
that she looks like a perfect convert so
he walked over to give her some alms and
preached the gospel to her when she got
close enough to him she stabbed him in
the stomach repeatedly she was so
insistent on trying to kill him that she
even dug our hands into his stomach and
pulled out his intestines on that very
same day Franz Ferdinand was
assassinated and it was one of the many
events that triggered the beginning of
world war one instead of being by that
Sauron serene assigned to give his
advisement Rasputin was stuck in a
Siberian hospital healing from his
injuries after hearing the news of the
impending Great War Rasputin wrote a
letter to the Tsar pleading with him to
not go to war he wrote we will all drown
in blood the disaster is great the
misery infinite but the sod did not want
to listen to Rasputin for the first time
in his career people were cheering for
him in the streets and they were
supporting fighting for the glory of
Russia the Tsar left the royal palace so
that he could fight with Russian
soldiers Alexandra was all alone and
after Rasputin healed he returned to the
royal palace and became her right-hand
advisor and Tsar by proxy over the
course of two years Rasputin personally
appointed several ministers of the
Interior but he was completely
uneducated in politics so the men he put
into power were completely incompetent
World War one was devastating millions
of Russian men died in this war he was
struggling to find work and the cost of
bread doubled on top of all of this the
Tsarina
trusted a madman the entire country that
had enough the Russian people they
basically had no choice but to have a
revolution
even though he survived the
assassination attempt and rescued
himself began to decline and soon enough
he could no longer heal people he wrote
in his journal that he knew that he
would die soon and he already had made
peace with it he believed that God was
about to make a sacrifice in order to
save the Russian people similar to how
Jesus Christ had died on the cross he
wrote - sorry nur Alexandre if one of
your relations brings upon my death and
none of your family will remain alive
for more than two years they will all be
killed by the Russian people tell your
relatives that I've already paid for
them in my blood
I shall be killed I am no longer among
the living
pray and be strong during a meeting in
Parliament one of the politicians
actually called Rasputin a dark force
and said that he was sick and tired of
this dirty peasant controlling the
country and that he would personally
kill him himself if the man was not
taken out of power
sorry nur Alexandra's nephew was a man
named Felix Yusupov and here was one of
the many people who wanted him dead he
heard a lot about rasputin's reputation
with the ladies Musa bhav was married to
a woman named Irina and she was
considered to be one of the most
beautiful women in the city of st.
Petersburg it was remanded that Yusupov
was bisexual and that the couple were
swingers with an adventurous sex life
the invite addressed Putin to join them
claiming this Irina had taken their open
relationship too far and that he
believed that she was stricken with a
sex addiction he said that she needed
Rasputin's helps you heal the demons
inside of her after gaining rasputin's
trust Yusupov met up with two of his
co-conspirators they were planning to
assassinate him the men picked up
Rasputin in a car and driven to the use
of both mansion where they led him into
a basement dining room the table was set
up to appear as though there just had a
large party they told him that Irina was
with her guests upstairs and that she
would come downstairs later to have her
healing ceremony they encouraged him to
eat and drink while they waited for her
with that in mind they started to hand
him tiny cakes and glasses of wine
Rasputin had no idea that all of the
food and drink was laced with cyanide to
Dolf hours later Yusupov could not
believe that Rasputin had not dropped
dead yet he began to believe the rumors
that he truly did have demonic powers
and that poison would not be enough to
kill him he rushed upstairs and grabbed
his revolver and returned to the
basement pointing
gun at Rasputin the monk simply stood
there staring straight ahead he did not
beg for his life or show any sign of
fear
he shot Rasputin who crumpled down to
the floor the men cheered and then went
upstairs to party after some time into
the celebration Yusupov began to feel a
sense of dread he walked down to the
basement with the doctor and leaned in
to check for a heartbeat rest Putin's
eyes opened and he lunged at Yusupov the
doctor fainted on the spot Yusupov
pushed the demon off him and scrambled
upstairs to tell his friends that
Rasputin's come back to life they ran
down to the basement and he was gone he
had crawled up the basement stairs and
was slinking his way across the
courtyard Yusupov shot him point-blank
in the head and five other men pulled
their revolvers out to riddle his body
with bullets
they stopped Rasputin's body in the
trunk of the car and drove him to a
river where they shoved him in a hole in
the ice when his body was later found
his hands were up as if he was pressing
against the ice in an attempt to escape
there was even water in his lungs
suggesting that he was still breathing
even after all of that after hearing the
story people were convinced that he had
truly come back to life again as a
zombie so indeed they dug up his body
and burned the remains but not before
cutting off and preserving his legendary
penis
indeed it is now on display in a museum
in some Petersburg
soon after his death Rasputin's prophecy
really did come true the entire Romanov
family was executed during the Bolshevik
Revolution and Russia would never be the
same again so I really hope you found
the video interesting if you did please
do give us a thumbs up below do not
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this several days a
week so hit that subscribe button hit
the notification bell and you'll learn
all about that and as always see you
next time
[Music]